I was like a real [__] uh real [__] bag
bad student and just kind of like
weasel my way in that and I was like
okay I'm here
still was just like a bad student in
college I thought I'd like reboot you
know like start over like Rebrand uh
that didn't happen uh
but then I discovered like oh you know
what I'm start like trying to write
movies and stuff and like then uh after
graduating from college was like okay
now I'm gonna move to LA finally Rebrand
you know and then I just met three
losers like myself and uh the rest is my
history yeah I remember
um
seeing uh you guys at the on the red
carpet of The Comedy Central roast of
Charlie Sheen uh-huh that was like right
when the Workaholics came yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and uh man it's it's turned into quite
the quite the career dude it was um the
game changer and like the best gig too
because it was like
we were like doing sketch comedy uh just
[__] around like
you know same as you guys kind of like a
crew that just was like let's roll on
this you know
um
and then after like six or seven years
of doing that
uh got the show and then the show just
was exactly what we needed was what was
exactly what a lot of people were
looking for and uh the success was
like perfect if you were able to do
creatively what you wanted to do like
everything everything and not only like
uh as far as like scripts and like
stories we pitched and stuff but just
like
you knew that if you were going to
improvise something you could say the
craziest [__] ever and then like
nobody would be like whoa hey man can we
can we talk to you for a second about
that like what are you talking about
your your landscapers doing a great job
out there
you know I gotta just like just slip
them like a ten dollar bill
you know
we're pretty loosey-goosey yeah
you live in a gorgeous neighborhood you
like to take care of it there's freaking
lawns in idiot mode like I'm not gonna
tell this guy he can't do his job all
right come on yeah
is reality
um but it would be nice if he wasn't
doing it yeah it's all good man yeah is
that because Comedy Central lets you
guys do whatever you want we were
nobodies like they were I was just
saying this is somebody the other day
like uh Nick Swardson hilarious stand-up
comedian in all these funny movies uh
Reno 9-1-1 got his own sketch show and
they were like giddy up here we go and
they kind of were just like super
Hands-On with that and we had a budget
of like 650 Grand an episode which is
nothing for them
[Applause]
maybe three oh yeah yeah well that's
just like Speedos though like how many
like what are you guys behind
[Music]
but so you know with production and like
Gaffers and sets and all this [__] right
right you know you're you're still
figuring it out and like they just
didn't Bank on us uh not in a negative
way they just were like yeah let's give
these kids a shot
um
and
you know I I we we got to make exactly
we wanted uh the way we wanted to make
it and uh just had the best time going
into a Workaholics did you did you guys
have this like special feeling that you
guys knew that it was gonna be as big as
it was
so will I am song I got a feeling it was
based on a conversation we had
on top of the Capital Records yeah yeah
um
no like our feeling was
we think this is funny and like we are
pretty hard on each other as far as like
that's not funny you know what I mean
like man we can do better and uh we
loved it we had a good time we thought
we were doing things that
um hadn't been done on TV yet we started
doing like these little adventures for
every episode it was less sitcomy and
more kind of like action comedy
um but just like shrunken down in scale
and uh push the envelope a little bit we
were relatable you know we were like
just dudes who wanted to like meet girls
and drink beer and like keep their job
and not get fired you know how did the
the Seth Rogue and the Zac Efron's come
into the fold was that like after the
show was already out and they were fans
yeah yeah I mean um we we dipped in we
dipped our toe into like the stoner
comedy world right yeah
um and so like the overlap with Seth's
fans uh was a thing so then we were on
his radar
um and so they brought us in to do
neighbors they had a montage oh yeah
where it was like our fraternity comes
from a long line of people who've uh
like created wonderful things for like
the world of partying right and it was
like in the 50s it was these people 60s
these people I think we were the 70s and
we invented like beer pong
um but I think like The Lonely Island
guys were like from the 30s or something
it was a bunch of like right
recognizable comedy people that in a
rapid fire succession
um Illustrated this fraternities history
man so that was pretty fun when you said
invented ping pong I just had this this
picture you know like in in Thailand
they famously have these women that
shoot ping-pong
I've never seen that yeah I I elected to
not go to that yeah but um but I just
thought like man what it might have been
funny if they showed you guys in like
the way you invented pink that was how
we did this
she ran out of the old poop squeezing it
out
um yeah I don't know I think the way we
did it was okay
no it was uh that would be great
different movie that's actually more
hour speed like uh which we did game
over man right and I got to be in it
and that was the best we're like uh will
you jump off this thing you're like this
is what I do
no problem uh and Seth produced that and
uh helped us kind of like shape the
story from what it originally was which
was like a
telephone with like a bunch of
celebrities he got taken over and then
we just had to like dial it back because
like it just was gonna be a scheduling
[__] nightmare to have uh so many
people and all that and if you go to
harrys.com
Stevo you get this whole starter kit
with foaming shave gel the way that
ergonomic handle the five blade razor
the travel cover to protect the razor
it's everything you need and it's a 13
value but they're gonna give it to you
for just three dollars if you go to
harrys.com Stevo